all right
heaven heaven where are you from
originally
Pasadena tell me about your family um I
am an only child and I had two great
parents um great parents I was their
life and I grew up in the sang gille
Valley and just I headed towards
Hollywood and that's how I ended up here
when things kind of deflated I guess you
could say how far did you go to school
11th grade yeah where did things go off
off the rails when I was 13 my parents
split and I ended up out here for the
first time and yeah it caused like
trauma for me that kept repeating so
it's a very serious thing to you know
the homeless thing is just it's been the
curse of my life it was an ugly divorce
or kind um no they were just they
weren't married but um because of the
split I ended up on the stre at a young
age and it um was like my biggest fear
and then it happened a couple more times
and it's like
it's like life is just I don't know it
seems like a nightmare come true
sometimes if that makes sense um yeah so
you ended up on the streets yeah yeah
they I'm sorry they split when I was 13
and I had a perfect life up until that
and um then being on the street at such
a young age was like
traumatizing and um you stayed in school
I tried to I tried to and um we would
get it back together again like me and
my mom or me and my dad and it happen
again kind of it happened this is my
fourth time being out here but this is
cuz of my own you know kind of four
choices I guess but um unlike other
people it's not due to drug use or
anything it's little lot of bad things
like bad luck kind of just brought me to
this and then I was like okay well now
let me just start drinking and using
drugs you know it's not like let me get
high than lose everything like some
people do that sounds yeah I don't know
it's um but drugs are a part of your're
just yeah they're just it's a coping A
coping mechanism for me it's just how I
cope with with out there what is your
drug I smoke crack and I drink sometimes
and where do you stay now I'm right now
with a friend but for the last year and
a half I've been outside with my dog
he's 12 it's been rough just wherever we
can stay like excuse me stay staying in
people's tents and things like that no
like on the actual Street like
like um cuz I don't like people and I
don't trust people so like it would just
be just me and my dog so like like I
would stay up as long as I could like at
a donut shop or at a 7-Eleven because I
don't feel safe and then I would find
like an an open car or truck and sleep
in that for a couple hours and move on
and just kind of things like that just
so that I could be alone and not in
someone's tent or something you know I
just that's definitely not safe and you
think it's the parent your parents split
spitting up that caused this um well the
first time it was but this last time
around um yes sorry I kind of left a
hole there um this last time I U my
father passed away in 2019 and he was my
best friend but I ended up with an
inheritance um so I thought I would just
come to Hollywood and live my dream and
get an apartment and and I was living my
dream but then I like fell in love and
that's where I really messed up cuz I
started trusting this person and um I
exhausted all of my money and uh I left
my life in someone else's hand and kind
of he just when he was done with me like
that was it he he put me out here
basically my ex-boyfriend John so yeah
he made sure I didn't have any money or
any means you know it was it was just
kind of I just I trusted him with
everything and I let him kind of be in
charge of like you know if I'm going to
eat or not kind of thing you know that
sounds dumb but he was very manipulative
and stuff he did the thing where like um
they call it what they call it Financial
it's some kind of abuse like with like
dangling things like you know I mean oh
you don't have to do anything I'll take
care of you and then little by little he
was paying for everything I didn't even
have money in my wallet and uh yeah I
just I just left everything in someone
else's hands which is the dumbest thing
you could ever do you know you're
trusting yeah I didn't even have my own
job my own savings nothing it was yeah
so when we broke up he made sure I had
nothing like and put me out here
basically cuz he was the maintenance guy
where I lived
so yeah he he made sure that the staff
all thought I was crazy and he knew I
didn't have a dollar to my name and you
know he promised me uh that he would
take care of me and he literally did the
opposite so I was just kind of thrown
out here with nothing at all like yeah
pretty much but he also got physical and
there's a lot more to it but yeah so how
old are you now I'm 40 and you have no
kids
no it's a blessing yeah yeah that's I
purposely didn't have kids you know cuz
yeah
um um yeah I feel like this isn't the
best story I feel like I'm probably not
can
we well I mean your your crack addiction
probably plays a large part in in your
troubles as well right um to be honest
it's not my biggest problem like no what
do you think is your biggest
problem um not wanting to
live yeah yeah like literally suicide
dark like seriously I wish I wasn't here
but I my dog needs me and um so I'm just
here for him really I mean if that
sounds yeah yeah have you seen doctors
for your
mental problems not this time no
cuz no I'm kind of just I'm just
floundering like every day is just like
foraging you know Hunter gather
lifestyle and just you know just mostly
for my dog how do you make money um I
sell my
body and even that's not my biggest
problem it sucks but you know yeah it's
definitely around here it's not it's not
good for your um your ego or no that's a
terrible
lifestyle it's yeah down here pretty
awful it can make you feel like you
know but it kind of is what it is you
know yeah but it's very dangerous is my
concern it's it's dangerous there's a
lot of really crazy people and ruthless
people that have no problem hitting a
woman and uh that's what I find
appalling that people are just okay with
that what's the worst thing you've seen
since you've been here I got beat up by
a security guard twice a man that's the
worst thing I've seen cuz it happened to
me um yeah that's pretty awful I
mean I had a black guy my first one in
my life was by a man and that was just
outrageous it was crazy you know there
are shelters for women there are but a
lot of them don't take dogs or whatever
so that's my I won't go anywhere without
my dog cuz he needs needs me so like
sorry my breathing's really shallow I'm
super nervous right now um you're doing
you're doing
fine what would you say heaven is your
biggest
regret living I'm just kidding um not
not taking the um initiative to just
continue working and keeping a savings
of my own you know and making sure that
I could fall back on something anything
completely trusting my ex-boyfriend was
really where messed up cuz blindly I
just trusted this man that I didn't
really know hardly who ended up to be
married and stuff which I didn't know so
his his whole his whole thing was just
literally I it wasn't me like I thought
he loved me and would take care of me
and that was my fault like blindly
trusting somebody you know he had a
whole wife and and child that um yeah I
didn't know about till the end so
um yeah just not having my own self to
fall back on cuz then like at the end
like like trying to find a job to so
that I wouldn't lose my apartment stuff
it was it was too late for that you know
it didn't work out
so yeah like I should have seen it
coming kind of thing right are you
learning from your
mistakes no I don't feel that I really
have any mistakes it's just survival you
know I'm not your typical person you
know like mistakes what's what do you
consider a
mistake trusting somebody that was
clearly not worthy of their oh yeah that
that that's it I should have known
better like um I guess trusting somebody
you know that was that's a regret for
sure yeah and your mom is still
alive yeah but she has dementia so yes
and no you know yeah I understand that
she's a she's a yeah yeah she's a shell
of herself which sucks it's it's all
just a weird time right now you know
it's it's like a nightmare to be honest
but there are good days and bad days you
know
have you considered going to rehab or
something like that yeah there's one I
want to go to so I'm trying to get in
there cuz it's really
nice yeah and I don't I don't do good in
front of cameras so I'm super nervous
but yeah I would like to change my life
at this point it's just kind of like I'm
in like limbo but yeah I would like to
go back to school do rehab maybe find a
good job and start over if you had a
goal of something you'd like to see
yourself doing in a few years what would
that
working and just being normal you know
going to school having bills to pay and
yeah driving a car all the things that
that make me not human anymore right
since I don't have them like yeah yeah
but I can I can possibly help you find a
place to go that's very nice we'll talk
about it after we're done um that would
be
wonderful emotionally what do you go
through it sounds like you're suicidal
sometimes I contemplate suicide much too
often for like a regular normal person I
just don't talk about it because I don't
want somebody to put me away you know um
I joke about it but it's it's on my my
mind a lot more than I feel like it
should be um but I'm Catholic I won't
act on it because I'm not saying that
all Catholics don't do that but it's
something I take very seriously like I
don't want to go to hell and if this is
already hell I don't want to see the
next level like level two sko is hell
for sure um just my life it could be
anywhere it could be but kidro doesn't
help you know it's it's I've never seen
anything like this place you know yeah
it's horrible it's pretty crazy hard to
believe it exists it's yeah right I'm
like do people drive by this and just
like they they drive by and just look at
the freak Show what the or they just
don't see it that's the part that is
scary to know that well it's a lot Tamer
now because so many people are in
housing so they're hidden away they're
in yeah they're in apartment buildings
all over the County of LA yeah and
that's good that's good good cuz I'm
just I'm just like how can you look if
you live in an apartment in Santa Monica
or Pasadena or North Hollywood or
somewhere and all of a sudden a crack
addict or fentel addict right is your
neighbor is your next door neighbor and
they need money tonight oh yeah no your
car is parked out there yeah definitely
yeah that that would Beary just bringing
drugs into the environment which right
yeah wasn't cuz I've been on that side
too I haven't always been on drugs um
but you got to realize your neighbor
could always be somebody who's um crazy
and means harm you just never know so
but yeah yeah that sounds nice to be the
person that the other side of it to be
the person that's afraid of like that
weirdo I don't want to be that weirdo so
sometimes I think it's almost better
just to keep everyone contained in one
small I think that's what this is right
is that what I'm not sure what the
answer is but I don't that's what I feel
like skido is cuz I'm like um that's
what it looks like you know kind of just
it's like the wild west but I don't
know I'm new to it and it's just very
it's like how I don't know how has this
always been here has always been here
yeah it's it's pretty much always been
here for the last it's pretty years I
mean just the dirtiness of it is to me
the part that's gross it's
filthy it's gross like there's this we
all know I don't have to talk about it
but it smells awful and it's like I mean
I'm not saying they should arrest people
that just go potty on the street but
there's porta potties like you don't
have to poop on the I mean the biggest
the biggest problem is the mental
illness problem which is pretty much
across the board down here yeah
everyone's dealing with it in one way or
another but there's nowhere to take
these people nowhere to put them they're
just putting them
in they're going to be your next to a
neighbor
and yeah in Santa Monica or or Culver
City or r or Duarte or whatever right
and you've got uh a crazy drug addict
that with the drugs the mental illness
with neighbor is that so dangerous and I
don't think people know how to deal with
that but it makes the city look better
right it's yes that's what looks the
Olympics happen in a couple years and
come that's why everybody suddenly right
everybody's in a hotel but me like I
can't get into a hotel like it it'll
appear much better yeah it looks good
but yeah I don't know if that's the I
think it's bad for the city in as a as a
whole right to to spread it all all over
everywhere that's definitely true yeah
because yeah it just brings crime and
all kinds of things people don't want is
in in their Community right into every
every Community now that's the word I
was just thinking the other day I'm like
Community I don't think of that word
when I think of skido I mean is it a
community not not quite well well the
the city the state the country doesn't
really want to deal with all the mental
health issues so they right they just
kind to let it it's a shame let it
happen and hide it as much as they can
yeah there a GU trying to fix the
problem right excuse me sorry to
interrupt you um that's the problem of
mine but there was a guy yelling what
last night or two all up and down each
Street for like a good hour yelling like
not making sense you could tell he had
something going on oh that happens every
minute nobody checked on him um you know
nobody drove up nobody asked if he was
okay like and I kind of wanted to but
knowing my luck I've bad luck no you
don't want to do that especially at
night yeah especially as a female forget
and I already have like I said I I meet
everyd the cops won't even that's
exactly cuz I I heard excuse me I heard
the ambulance and some people driving by
and like um at first I thought the
Department had stopped but it was
somewhere else and right yeah no and he
just kept going I was like is he okay
and um he just finally just left but now
you're going to start seeing that all
over the county right how's that going
to be in Arcadia or like where where
this just an old people community that
would be scary you know excuse
me but yeah I don't want to be that
person and if I don't leave here like
soon that's probably going to be me like
in 5 years like yeah what's your biggest
fear
wow um not being able to get away from
somebody
um I've been lucky yeah pretty lucky
it's great that you're not pregnant or
you don't have a child no yeah we'll see
my my dog I almost said my son my dog
Lord
Byron excuse me he's like my child cuz
he's this big and I carry him a lot cuz
he has bad hips but he's also old and so
when we do have to like get away like
let's say somebody gets weird or
whatever the reason we have to leave um
it's hard to like make sure that I'm
caring him or like you know we're
running or he's on the leash and we'
we've had to run for our lives and yeah
it's like having a child you know and
I'm grateful I don't have a little one
too to be like pulling along it's that's
the scary part you know uh I I'm I'm
being kind of vague but I've had some
instances where just people
snap and to be honest as a woman whether
you
you give give it up or don't there's
always going to be someone that's going
to get all the way crazy with you so
we've had to do some um odd things to be
safe like where you it's a lot it's do
do you think your situation that you're
currently in is is is due to
your lack of
self-worth that's an
interesting an attractive female of your
from
your with your background wouldn't
typically allow herself to get into this
situation no um I gave up on everything
so I'm just
like hey if we eat today and you
know whatever if we have somewhere to
sleep it okay you know like I've given
up but yeah no normally no this is my
biggest nightmare um to have nothing and
to have to sell my
body crack isn't even the big crack's
just whatever nicotine crack it's all
the same to me a habit is a habit and um
one day I'm just going to go okay I
don't want this anymore but like what I
do for a living is pretty repulsive and
I could have a lot more money I just
don't apply myself cuz I don't
want to cuz it's gross um so yeah I I
have some selfworth in there somewhere
um but not enough to be like that's the
thing what what where would I go like
okay I don't want this for me anymore
what am I going to do get up and just
like you know walk off to like I'm I'm
from Hollywood I don't even have anybody
over there that I don't have anyone I
don't have any friends so it's a lot I'm
in hell and I meet random people like
the gentleman that brought me here um
but I view everyone as a threat because
the majority of the time they are they
want the one thing that I have um and if
I don't just give it away they'll
probably just take it so it's it's a
nightmare for women I think when you
were younger or even now do you did you
have dreams of a different life
yeah I wanted to be a pastry chef and
then a pinup model
and it would be nice yeah cuz I'm good
at baking but now I'm just like like I
said if I get money for food and and for
crack then it's a good day like I've
been wanting donuts and McDonald's for
like four
days so yeah that's the goal that's so
cool I want 40 piece chicken nuggets and
some donuts and I can help you with some
of those what uh have you been ever been
in love before yeah like
twice but um yeah that was nice to me
that seems like such a far away like um
you know like a
dream I don't believe in that stuff
anymore you know God I'm so dark I'm
yeah I'm the Dark Side of like some
people are just out here having a great
time and I look at them like you
like I I don't want everybody sad like
me but I just I don't want to see that
kind of happiness cuz well I think
they're just in denial of the reality of
their lives yeah you get people that
come here to like they have homes they
found a drug that really helps them numb
right or they come and just party here
yeah I'm like yeah I didn't know that
was a thing it's a total thing and I'm
just
like I don't know it's it triggers me
and knowing they can go back to their
homes and their families and I'm just
like this is this is a playground here
where anyone can do anything they want
I'm like why the cops stop here though
like I don't know you know I try not to
judge people but um yeah no it is like
the Wild West it's
very yeah sorry I'm so boring I'm sorry
no you're not boring at all um oh oops
no you don't think so not at
all yeah
so what what have you learned about
people about men from doing from living
on streets like
this people don't really care the
majority of people I don't like to
generalize but people don't really care
what you're going through they just want
you to look pretty and be be cute and
happy till it you know and do what they
want as it suits them or don't
ask for don't be sad don't cry
don't don't be in pain and and do
what they say be at their beck and call
even if they're not giving you
anything because they might kill you or
they like they'll intimidate you so that
you think they might hurt you so that
you'll give in and that's another thing
if you act scared or if they know the
trauma you've endured they'll use that
against you even if they're actually not
going to hit you they're going to act
like they're going to hit you or
whatever the and I don't fight men
so I have you know trouble with that you
know someone was chasing me last night
and I don't run from anything I'm not
afraid of things but like to a point you
know excuse me um I'm a realist I I
would not win if I'm trying to fight a
man but so I'm going to run if he's
getting too close to me and he means
harm I'm going to run so it's just
that's what I've learned I learned that
people are monsters and then they don't
have to be men but the
majority they're either men or or people
that just want what you have and and you
know even if I'm not trying to like I
don't know I'll dress like a man to try
and it's even when I dress like a boy
like it's like even harder like it's
even more I get more attention um cuz
people were like oh is that a girl let's
you know let's look harder let's get
closer and it's it's weird it sounds
funny out loud but yeah is it hard for
you to trust men now after you what
you've seen oh yeah I don't trust
anybody
really I mean I if I'm in a situation
like like this is different um kind of I
mean I'm just going to say it you're
white I'm half white I trust white
people more than anyone else because
that's just how it is um that's just
where I'm at right now based on your
experiences mhm and I mean I've had
white guys trip out on me but the
majority are other races and uh and also
it's daytime and you know but I if I'm
in a situation with a man in a enclosed
space um whatever happens is kind of my
fault because I walked into that you
know it's it's scary to always have to
be on a high alert like that but you
have to put yourself in dangerous
situations in order to survive and make
money all the time yeah all the time
yeah how how do you think you have
changed from from doing that for for
years now um I feel
like you would think that like I would
lose all self-respect because of the
thing and kind of to a point but it's
like I've gotten a lot smarter I'm
surprised at my ability to um how I've
been able to survive like survival mode
I'm not a tomboy by like at all I've
never been a tomboy but I mean I've
strapped my dog to me with like a scarf
and like climbed and like gotten
through windows and turned electricity
on and the gas on and done weird
that I've never thought I've had to do
and you know not get caught and like lay
low and just to break into places where
I could stay warm and stuff and um I
don't think a year ago that me knew how
to do anything any of that like but you
didn't you didn't come from that kind of
no no I mean background your family was
not like that no I was the only only
child and I'm a girl and so I was very
much you know I didn't climb trees I I
don't think I knew how to climb a tree
um so now if I had to climb a tree to
like get onto a roof to get into an open
window to get into a closet where I
could be safe or something that's how I
look at things now I'm like I look at
everything as a ladder like whereas
before I wouldn't have even known to so
it's I'm grateful for that the Instinct
you know yeah yeah do you think it's
would if you had to put a finger on what
put you in this situation at 40 years
old is it your parents separating or is
it oh no and I'm sorry I'm kind of
messed up with that so
like um when the first time I was
homeless I was 13 it was cuz they
separated um and like my dad left me
with my mom as he thought he should and
she you know she lost the apartment
whatever and she went all crazy and like
Left Me by myself so I was out here at a
young age and that that's what me
up I think for my whole life and then I
started using using drugs and I've
always had a battle with um crystal meth
you know off and on but then I was going
to be a nun in 2015 and I was celibate
and I didn't touch drugs or booze for
like 8 years and I was fine really so I
mean that was totally yeah um so like
but the reason I'm out here this time is
cuz one person I feel like I'm literally
blaming my ex-boyfriend cuz it was
literally him like he did it I didn't
mention every single thing but he
literally did it like the trust thing
that was me but I did everything I could
to avoid this I even sold my brand new
car I just I just got ripped off by it's
a lot of a series of really bad things
happened but it was all due to this one
person so like and you you deciding to
trust him yeah and he he went out of his
way to ruin my life and I hate
him
so he's a jerk and you know I I see him
sometimes and um his his indifference is
the part that's like he's he's not a
human you know his eyes just there's
nothing there when he looks at me and
that's scar as as
like yeah yeah it's weird you know it's
it's strange to encounter a heartless
person he's definitely he exhibits signs
of from what I've read like his signs of
like psychopath like and I'm not the
person to like use these terms and be
like Oh but I read a lot I I research
he's literally he's just like he
has a lot of you know traits yeah and it
makes sense now it's very strange to
encounter it's so weird cuz he's
he's a saint in everybody else's eyes
someone I interviewed who I remember
reading a comment early on somebody said
no this this is a psychopath look out
and I thought that was the strangest
comment right because it's like well who
are you to say is if you look it up you
know they have their signs and traits
and right but now that I've now that
years have gone by I I see that that
comment was right on the money really
with this person you you can't really
tell either by I I was so naive I
couldn't see it yeah but now I see it
very clearly and it's it's the strangest
personality to ever encounter right they
seem so nice they seem so nice and my
mom always taught me if somebody's too
nice don't trust them and he was like
way too nice he was perfect that's what
got me to like like him in the beginning
like he was well I think what the
mistake a lot of us make is we we want
to trust somebody right for whatever
reason you know maybe maybe you think
they're sweet or they're nice or you're
attracted or whatever yeah but you you
think like oh this person's trustable
and you've you've decided that you've
you've already imprinted that on their
yeah on that on their
personality and and the truth is they're
they're the one you shouldn't because
that's what I did I put all of my my
trust in and I because I I still miss my
father we're best friends and so when I
found this guy and I was like he's like
I'll take care of you I won't let
anything happen to you I clung to that
and little did I know I was clinging to
the one person that was going to
everything up probably knowing the whole
time he was going to do that like and um
yeah he was all I had I ran to him and
he was abusive and I I kept running back
to him and that's the worst feeling ever
did do you no longer trust your
intuition yes and no cuz after trauma
your mind gets all up like yeah
so no cuz I but at the same time um I'd
rather not trust anybody and flee from
everyone excuse the microphone or
because then you know that's kind of
where I'm at rather than uh thinking I
can trust anybody so I kind of trust it
mean because it tells me don't trust
anyone you have to trust it with all the
people you're interacting with and
that's just to do business with yeah
yeah all of it I hate it I hate people
um the majority of the time you know
it's it's been my biggest nightmare
being out there with no privacy and just
um I don't even know whose clothes these
are just they're mine now but like it's
it's it's the worst it's like these I
think these are my shoes um they don't
are you doing things now that you just
never dreamed you would ever be doing
well there's that I mean look if I see a
hoodie that looks dry and it's been in
the Sun I'm going to wear it because the
sun is bleaching it like it's using its
power to like it's the best bleaching
agent in the world like you know it
makes things smell good and so I'm going
to put that h on like that's pretty
gross it's awful um my last two pairs of
Vans I found and they happen to fit
so yeah those are crazy like but
survival I guess you know but yeah it's
pretty nutty it's well let's see what we
can do about maybe getting you back to a
normal life that would be amazing see
what I can do
uh Heaven what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life um don't never trust your instinct
that little like voice just always
listen to it even if it's just
saying this person's bad for you or you
know don't stop going to school or hey
don't move there or it's going to tell
you because um I really do feel like
this is my
ex-boyfriend's if he did this to me
right like basically that's where I'm at
and um when I first met him I heard in
my mind like don't trust this guy don't
don't do it you know don't don't trust
him and I was like so I don't know it
could have maybe been avoided but I'm
just kind of also dumb I'm a hopeless
romantic and we were texting and it just
seemed all nice and fun so I just went
for it so yeah always trust your
instinct like listen to that all right
yeah Heaven thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you let's see
if we can do by getting you some help
that would be amazing thank you
bye